in Albania's back streets there is
little light even less hope
these Alleyways are home to some of the
country's poorest
and collater Farah's life is deprived
her desperation overwhelming
I don't want to see my children on the
streets she tells me
I want them to live well I don't want to
see them begging
so this is the upstairs her 16 year old
son cledi shows me around
one bedroom for seven people to make
money the kids sell scraps they find in
the city's bins
lady shows me a tattoo pen he's made
from the rubbish he dreams of being a
tattoo artist but mostly he dreams of
escaping this country to the UK like
tens of thousands of others why do you
want to go to the UK
foreign
foreign
this charity delivers food to 17 000
families in need one in 10 albanians
live in poverty poverty that's fueling
migration
every day we hear that people are trying
to move outside of the country because
the reasons are different one of one
family needs to go for a better life one
needs to go for better school one for
better uh Health Center one for uh
better work they pay uh three or four
times much more than in Albania a desire
to escape boosts people traffickers
trade twelve thousand albanians are
among those to cross the channel in
small boats to England this year
Maria whose name and voice has been
changed negotiated with Smugglers to
send her son to the UK but in the end
couldn't afford the fee
a perilous journey in flimsy dinghies or
hidden in the back of trucks seen as
worth it for the chance of a new future
you only live once live like warm or
drawn because there is no other option
this is the way live like warm or risk
your life you have to put yourself in
danger
a Crackdown on Smugglers May disrupt the
boats crossing the channel but without
hope and opportunities at home Albania's
illegal migrants will keep on coming
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Tarana Albania